HANDING OFF THE VACCINE TO THE
STATE."
DANA?
>> Dana: BLAKE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LET’S BRING IN
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
HERE’S A STATEMENT ABOUT THIS
SCUM OF.
THIS PACE, 60 MILLION AMERICANS
WILL BE VACCINATED BY THE END
OF JANUARY AND A THIRD DOSE WILL
EXPIRE EVEN WHEN KEPT IN A DEEP
FREEZING SYSTEM.
THAT MEANS MILLIONS OF CRUCIAL
DOSES OF THE VACCINE WILL GO TO
WASTE.
THAT IS KIND OF INFURIATING.
WHAT YOU THINK THE PROBLEM IS?
>> ABSOLUTELY, RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
500,000 AMERICANS BEING
VACCINATED AND ARE SUPPLIED, WE
ARE SHIPPING OUT 7 MILLION
VACCINES EVERY DAY.
WHILE WE ARE STOCKPILING ALL OF
THESE VACCINES, ARE NOT BEING
DISTRIBUTED, THERE IS A SHELF ON
THEM, THEY CANNOT STAY FOR A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME.
WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN, THE STATES
NEED TO RAMP UP, THEY NEED TO
ELICIT THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
THEY HAVEN’T BEEN DOING THAT.
THEY STARTED OUT BY ONLY GIVING
IT TO CERTAIN HOSPITALS AND THEN
THEY GIVE TIGHT RESTRICTIONS ON
WHO WAS ALLOWED TO BE
VACCINATED.
ALL THESE SUDDEN IT TURNS INTO
THIS COMPLEX DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS WHEN IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ALL HANDS ON DECK, GIVE IT TO
THE HOSPITALS, GIVE THE
PRIVACIES THE PRIVATE SECTORS,
ANYBODY WHO WANTS ONE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GET ONE RIGHT NOW.
NEW YORK CITY, THEY’RE BENT TO
POP UP CENTERS IN THE LAST
24 HOURS AND PEOPLE ARE BEING
TURNED AWAY BECAUSE THEY DON’T
HAVE AN APPOINTMENT.
THEY WERE LINED UP FOR HOURS.
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAID HE
IDENTIFIED A THOUSAND SITES,
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN MOBILIZED
LAST MONTH.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY’RE
ONLY NOW BEING LOOKED AT.
THEY HAVEN’T EVEN BEEN OPEN YET!
>> Dana: IT’S VERY
FRUSTRATINING.
SO MANY PEOPLE WANT TO GET IT SO
THEY CAN GET BACK TO WORK AND
THEIR LIVES AND TRAVEL.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE, THERE IS SOME CONCERN
THAT EXCESSIVE ALCOHOL MIGHT
AFFECT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
VACCINE.
WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW?
>> DANA, WE KNOW CHRONIC
ALCOHOLISM IS ABSOLUTELY A
SUPPRESSANT, IT SHOWS AN
ALCOHOLIC, THE FLU VACCINE MAY
BE LESS EFFECTIVE.
CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM IS DIFFERENT
THAN MODERATE, BINGE DRINKING.
THERE IS A DOCUMENTARY THAT’S
BEING AIRED TOMORROW WHERE YOU
HAVE A RESEARCHER WHO CHECKED
WHITE BLOOD CELLS, THAT’S WHAT
MAKES THE ANTIBODIES BEFORE AND
AFTER DRINKING THREE GLASSES OF
PRESS ECHO AND THE RESULTS SHOW
THERE IS A 50% DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF THOSE CIRCULATING
WHITE CELLS AFTER THE THREE
GLASSES OF PRESS ECHO.
THAT BEING SAID, BY ANY STRETCH
OF THE IMAGINATION, OF HAVING
THREE GLASSES OF PRESS WINE, BUT
TELL YOU THAT CHRONIC ALCOHOL,
BINGE DRINKING WILL HAVE AN
EFFECT ON YOU, NOT ONLY MAY IT
THWART THE EFFORTS OF THE
VACCINE, BUT IT MAKES YOU MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO INFECTIONS,
SPECIFICALLY PNEUMONIA.
YOU WANT TO WATCH THAT ALCOHOL
INTAKE, ESPECIALLY AS WE HAVE
SEEN THE DRINKING THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC.
>> Dana: I’M THINKING OF